again well done ABC they did exactly
what their job was attract eyes they did
it that's what award ceremonies are for
but in terms of the science behind
gender uh dysphoria you're very familiar
with that so very familiar it's not
about the chromosome excuse me the
chromosomes within are both no this is
why sometimes like it people look at me
stupid when I say sometimes I don't need
to study because I remember back in the
day they're they're producing all these
goddamn studies that were saying this
we're saying that like trying to
convince me that men were women and
women were men vice versa
um and I just don't need to see a study
to know that's kind of you know